there is something that has risen up
um in the um
20s the 20 year olds 20 to 30 year olds
even 20 to 35 year olds right now that
we're seeing
almost on a moment moment-by-moment
basis in all of our interactions
uh with you guys out there through
broadcasting and through all the other
ways we interact with you
uh the positive is there's this
tremendous
that this generation whatever we're
calling these 20-somethings um
has this tremendous entrepreneurial zeal
in drive
and this this this sense to be
independent
it's not greed driven it's uh initiative
it's very positive it really is it's a
wonderful character attribute you've got
that that's how you got these rental
properties
and that drive is causing these
20-somethings
to do two things and oftentimes poorly
because they're doing them too quickly i
did this in my 20s
but i'm a boomer which now is a put down
but used to be just a demographic but um
but uh now i've got old man house shoes
you know so there you go
but the uh uh the the this wonderful
zeal this wonderful entrepreneurial zeal
is causing
these 20-somethings to buy real estate
because i got to buy real estate
i'm going to get rich in real estate i'm
going to get rich in real estate now
when i was in my 20s
is when infomercials started oh that was
the beginning of infomercial oh yes
i'm going to get rich in real estate i'm
going to get rich in real estate
and i grew up in the real estate
business and so i went straight into i'm
going to get rich in real estate and i
did i became a millionaire by the time i
was 26 and
uh the other it's driving this bitcoin
craze it's driving this game stop crazy
yes
yes uh the same zeal is driving
people to do these things and to get out
there and i'm gonna turn over i'm gonna
do something i'm
gonna get something i'm gonna and it's
not greed it's the
spirit on it i mean that my discernment
says it's not greed it is
initiative it's it's a positive ambition
but what caused what happened with me
was i bought real estate that i couldn't
afford
i leveraged it i used totally borrowed
money and i ended up with 4 million
worth of real estate that i owed 3
million on so i had a million dollar net
worth
but it wasn't cash flowing and i was
flipping it and it was barely
cash flowing like his is barely cash
flowing this is why i know this math
because i lived it
right because i did the same thing only
i did it with more zeros on the end it
wasn't 400 000 is 4 million
and it took me down because the bank got
sold and called our notes
and uh then and i didn't have any cash
i was not in it i had all these assets
but there was no cash
and when you do that with real estate is
when you're gonna go broke
not when you're gonna make a fortune in
real estate and so real estate that does
not have margin
is not a blessing it's a liability and
investing in things that don't have
margin
or that are a high risk gamble play
is a misuse of your entrepreneurial
ambitious zeal
and so i love the zeal what i want to do
is channel it
with some wisdom and a process some
wisdom
yes and that is slow down a little bit
yeah and pay cash
and don't invest everything you have in
super high risk
crap um i mean and
i i know there's stories of people
making money in bitcoin i know there's
stories of people making money
with gamestop we talked to one here on
the other day i'm not saying it can't
happen
but i know stories of people made money
at the roulette wheel too that's right
i know people that made money on wheel
of fortune
but that doesn't mean our jeopardy got
personal friends that that
won and they won 50 000 bucks or
something but they didn't change their
career to be game show operators
right and they didn't put everything
they had that didn't push all their
chips to the center of the table on one
hand of cards
and that's what we're doing when we go
into highly leveraged real estate into
businesses with no margin
or high risk investment plays and we act
like it's a freaking game
right because we put all the chips in
the center table now if you've got a
small percent of your chips and you're
going to lose those and it doesn't kill
you that's different i don't even
recommend that but i'm not going to make
fun of you for that right
i am going to call you out on the other
because this this
you know it leads to uh bad critical
thinking that
okay real estate's a good investment so
all real estate no matter how broke i am
is a good investment that's right
that's bad thinking skills it is and
that's what happened with
in the 90s with day trading uh it's what
we're seeing now with bitcoin and
gamestop
uh but i'm gonna tell you something dave
i'm getting these callers calling in
these millennials
on my show the chris hogan show that are
saving and investing and following the
plan and the trail
is the foundations course they took in
high school
that they were either financial peace
babies where their parents went through
it
taught them or they went through
foundations and so they've got this
learning foundation literally where
they're thinking and following the
process
yeah it's encouraging i had people you
know when i'm doing real estate deals
i had people that thought i was a genius
when i was buying all that real estate
um except the old people
and the old people that had money kept
looking at me going son you're too
leveraged you've got no cash
this is going to catch up with you
you're going to get a spanking
you're going to get it and i kept going
oh you're just old you don't understand
this is a proper use of capital markets
and i used all the cash ketchup
you know i've got i've got great
internal rates of return
i have no cash right no liquidity i
couldn't buy a freaking loaf of bread
you know but i got four million dollars
for the real estate and so
this idea that you can throw around all
your arrogant little terms and all they
show is your immaturity
they don't show that i'm a dinosaur they
show that you're a child
that's all it shows and so the thing is
use this ambition this movement which is
so positive in this generation
in a slower more methodical cash basis
way
with high margins and then you're going
to learn love real estate i got a bunch
of real estate
and i want you to have some too i just
don't want to have you there it is